[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i wrote this piece because recently i
injured my left side and i was stuck
with just using my right hand during
practice
when i was practicing i found it very
difficult to
spot myself when the hand position
changes so for example from here
all the notes are in this position
and i have to jump over to the a
[Music]
so of course i look at the hand
positions as this
and then
this is sort of
divided in two
but when i was trying to bring it up to
tempo i found it very helpful to spot
myself with these off rhythms that i put
in
so this is the beat
[Music]
and a lot of the semitones happen
not on the beat
[Music]
then on the flip side i focused on the
lowest notes of each little section
[Music]
other than that another difficulty i had
was to keep the precision in the tips of
my fingers while having to stretch my
hands so even a stacked fifth like this
my hand has to be stretched to feel
comfortable to play
these three notes
but what happens when the hand is flat
is that the surface area of the finger
that you're using to press the keys
becomes a lot wider a lot bigger
and i find that is is a little
uncomfortable because sometimes if it's
too much you'd bleed over to the next
note and especially at the speed
if the focal point isn't narrower this
key is smaller than
what you're using to play it
so what i did to practice this is to
curl the tips of my fingers at every
single note and play this at a very slow
speed
[Music]
so another thing is endurance for this
piece of course it's very short so it's
not so much of a problem but it is with
the right hand only and it goes at a
very fast tempo
and for the majority of the piece my
hands especially with my size
is stretched out so there's a lot of
tension there's a lot of straining
involved so going back to the first
point i made about anchoring myself to
hear and feel the top ends and the low
ends of each of the different runs
it also helps with relaxation because as
you're making these subtle accents at
those points
it really gives you a chance to drop
into those notes and as you're doing
that you can relax your forearm and your
wrist
so that you're releasing some some
tension there
[Music]
so that's generally it about this piece
and i thank you for watching i'll see
you next time